pour la troisième fois en 13 mois les
rues de Toronto se couvrent de pancarte
électorale
[Musique]
visiblement la course ne suscite pas
beaucoup d'intérêt
[Musique]
s une campagne tranquille pourtant dans
le cas Toronto ce n'est pas faute de
candidats avec une trentaine de
personnes qui convoitent la mairie mais
ces nombreuses candidatures ont été
éclipsées par celle du maire sortante
John Tory qui brille un troisième mandat
dans son quartier général quelques
bénévoles font des appels pendant que le
maire lit son journal ici on ne sent pas
l'effervescence qui règne souvent dans
les bureaux de campagne car l'équipe
c'est qu'elle mène largement dans les
sondages
le maire sortant fait le pari que
l'électorat voudra miser sur son
expérience
si je n'avais pas produit de résultats
je ne serai pas un candidat compétitif
affirme John Tori le maire sortant se
targue d'avoir livré la marchandise mais
ce constat est loin d'être partagé par
tous les Torontois beaucoup ont plutôt
l'impression que leur Villepin a offrir
les services de base pénurie de logement
rue salles nid Paul manque de
pesticlables et transports publics
laborieux
progressistes croient cette torontoire
a aussi entendu de la part de ses rivaux
sont souvent accusés de manquer
d'ambition
il n'a rien fait en huit ans et le
logement abordable est un échec à lancer
le principal rival de gentory Gil
penalossa
oui il y a des problèmes et je ne suis
pas satisfait admettent il promet
toutefois de régler ces questions qu'il
attribue notamment à la pandémie
car Toronto se relève difficilement de
la crise la métropole enregistre un
déficit d'environ un milliard de dollars
le maire sortant promet de résorber sans
hausse de taxes et ce même si Toronto à
l'un des taux d'imposition les plus bas
de la province
les gens veulent payer plus de taxes ils
n'ont qu'à choisir un autre candidat
dans Gran turry
nous suivons le maire sortant alors
qu'il fait campagne en banlieue ouest de
Toronto dans ce restaurant somalien et
gentory est accueilli en vedette ses
promesses de réduire la violence armée
et de garder les taxes basses séduisent
visiblement
si quelqu'un qui promouvoit la diversité
explique cette sympathisante
deuxième arrêt de campagne dans une
épicerie perce du nord de Toronto ici
aussi gentory est entouré de visages
amis et essaye de conquérir les indécis
mais dans une allée un électeur
n'intercepte
le citoyen reproche au maire sur tant de
miner la vie démocratique on se
présentant une troisième fois j'attends
de lui de comprendre ça et quand c'est
le temps de se retirer et donner la
chance aux autres gentory est claire
cette campagne sera sa dernière
ce serait aussi un record de longévité à
la tête de la plus grande ville du
Canada mais pour ça il faudrait que les
électeurs choisissent encore gentory
rien n'est tout à fait joué avant le 24
octobre ici à Radio-Canada Toronto